you ever had a first flow
yeah who hasn't right
my first love was football
i was raised five years in iowa
and
[Applause]
are you from iowa
hey man let me have something what do
you think about this electricity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's just funny
[Music]
oh god quit it terry
nice to stand in front of the sears
roebuck window
on main street in clinton iowa
i brought there
you stood there you too what is this
you don't talk unless i ask you to
i'm being paid up here don't forget
you're not getting paid
no you paid
nothing
matter of fact you can talk i don't care
but you stood there
at the at the sears window
and i looked in and had all the hawkeye
stuff
and i loved and get this it was like one
of those what do you call it premiumness
was that what you call it
yeah that who said that
where'd you graduate
you got a college degree
gotta that's a big word
premonition yeah it's good can you spell
it so i'm priming i'm prima i'm
premonitioning
and i'm seeing that black and gold
helmet and
and all that uniform and i see that
football there and i got if santa claus
would bring me a football i'd be the
happiest guy in the world
and i got it
and i got my first football and it was
like you know i smelled it you put my
hands on it
it was just love at first touch
you